The earliest versions of the camera have been known to have existed from 300 BC
where even philosophers like Aristotle were actually looking at
how they can capture light onto a background plate and be able to use that for
looking at scenes.
The earliest forms of the camera started appearing in mid 1800s, and
this is one of those traditional classic examples of
a camera where basically a box with a lens or an optical capturing device,
which could be a pinhole, was used to generate images.
Then of course came various types of processes where you could now
be able to save those images onto print forms, and
this is various types of printing mechanisms that started in the early 1900s.
1948 is where we started getting more of these compact representations.
1986 perhaps is when we start seeing examples of these disposable cameras.
This is an instance of a first generation digital single-lens reflex,
or SLR, camera,
a professional camera that was a digital camera came about in early 1990s.
And this was about to 1 to 2 megapixel resolution image.
And more interesting thing was when I started my career on research and
computation photography, this camera was available for about $25,000.
And I actually got access to going to the lab to
be able to use this to take a few pictures so I can actually start get
playing around with the images that came from these specialized cameras.
Of course, 2000 is where the first generation of mobile cellphone cameras
started coming about.
So if you really think about it, we've gone a long way, where first instance of
a real camera that actually was into a form that we think of a camera to be in
right now, was in mid to early 1800s, to where we are now.
And of course, cameras have taken very interesting shapes and forms since then.
Interesting things to note now is cameras can be really small.
Just few examples.
As small as a pencil or
even as, you know, small enough to be on your, just your fingertip.
Most popular cameras that you see these days are,
of course, the cellphone cameras.
They provide a good resolution.
We played around with them a lot, I'm sure.
And of course, these days, people wearing them in different forms, including,
of course, much more variable cameras like this one.
One thing I'd like to note is one of the other things that has changed is how we
interact with these cameras.
In the old days, when we had the cameras in much more of a bigger form factor,
we had much more of a formal relationship,
where we basically use this tripods and all that kind of stuff.
Then we went to much more of a standup, but
if you notice, most of our camera interaction is much more now stand-away, and,
you know, we use viewfinders to be able to see it, and it's become more casual.
We've gone from more formal types of photography to
more casual photography more and more now